okay hey everyone it's Michael Volos
from orderflows and this is the
orderflows market analysis for uh
Tuesday July 11 2017 now uh Market got
quite a shock today when uh Donald Trump
Jr released his emails and uh the market
sold off in the snps um it was right
around the time that I was looking for
the market to Rally but uh but anyway uh
let's just jump right into it you know
tomorrow we got Janet Yellen talking
before uh Congress congress senate um
tomorrow so you know might be a little
bit quiet uh leading up into that and as
she started statements but anyway brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
Contract or make any other type of
investment decision futur training
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results as usual
the tools we use in this presentation
are are the orderflows trader and the
Delta scalper so uh let's just get
started let's take a look at um first
I'll talk about the the five years since
that was the uh the very easy trade uh
this
morning
um okay so you know around uh 3 in the
morning you had a ratio you had a
Divergence in the market right IED again
I talk about these things every day um
you know 329 here you got the single
print one you got a Divergence you got
the positive Delta and you see the
market start railing railing railing
around 10: you know it was kind of a
slow morning actually I mean we had very
tight range and obviously after uh 10 uh
around 10:15 when when the emails hit
the Twitter account uh the market took
off but um you know really quick in the
uh
snps um we'll just jump to the we'll
start with the four range chart there's
some interesting things in the 4 range
chart okay so going back in the
morning uh what was it here so you know
1:30 in the morning Chicago time first
you got your ratio on a Divergence
Market sold off rallied back up ratio
Divergence again and then Market sold
off more dramatically from your high
down um close to your lows sideways and
then made new lows you know once the
cash uh sorry uh before the cash open
704 um Cash open we made new lows now
you know at this time here we had this
low didn't have you had a Divergence but
you didn't have a ratio then the next
bar you got a ratio which you know that
alone is to me is bullish and then you
get the Delta scalper and you get a
stacked inbalance so again you I'm
looking at this time is is is very
bullish here and we just sort of went
sideways sideways sideways and then you
know this was uh what was that 8:45 is
this morning was it until you know 30
minutes later that we started rallying
up from this uh 22 area we got up to 25
sold back down uh sorry um got up here
at this point on the 10 range chart I
was I was bullish you know here around
10:00 obviously everything changed when
this
news you know when Trump decided to
tweet out those emails but anyway you
know you did have the Delta scalper give
a sell right here um you got the price
rejector at this the swing High you got
a bearish ratio and then the market just
Tanked
it just tanked it just fell over then
you hit this this low here you got the
Delta scalper giv a buy but it's on a
red candle so I'm not really interested
in it here you got a Divergence no ratio
um we start working our way back up back
up back up but um you know that that was
the interesting thing in the
uh in the snps I'm going to try and keep
this one a bit short a bit pressed for
time oh what was it okay so really quick
the other thing was
um eurocurrency okay so I don't normally
look at the 15-minute charts but this
this morning you know something that
caught my eye which which I thought was
was kind of interesting uh where was it
here okay so you know we had hit this
High
here at uh 7:30 at uh 45 A5 or sorry 55
and a half then you started selling down
down down then you started rallying back
up here now
you this is not your high it's the next
bar off your high you got strong
negative Delta 600 minus Delta 500 minus
259 then 18 and then we were in this bar
I remember point of control was just
below this point of control we had this
buying imbalance here we had some decent
volume we had a positive Delta and to me
it looked like this Market was ready to
Rally back up to the high then this bar
closed next bar you know went higher and
then you know got slammed here then it
recovered back and then made the new
highs you know so on the 15-minute chart
you know just by reading the Delta you
know honestly I would have been stopped
out on on this on this trade I don't
normally trade 15minute charts I just
happen to be looking at it and was
explaining to people in the room about
it but you know compare that this one of
the reasons why I don't particularly
like 15-minute you know minute based
charts versus um time based charts I'm
going to pull up the time based chart
here really
quick yeah it just looks cleaner on the
time based chart so uh let's make it a
little bit
smaller
okay go back to that time here so you
know this is this is that high okay then
you got the uh Delta scalper giv a sell
you sell
off Delta scalper gives a buy another
sorry this is this is the high okay this
is here where are we here right here
this is around 7 whatever
740 okay so there okay so you start
selling off and then Delta scoper gives
a buy you rally back up very fast the
market sold off and recovered this is
you know 908 and this is till 910 so you
know in a period of 2 minutes we sold
off about uh you know from 50 down to
37 basically then worked our way back up
but you got this Buy Signal here with
the Delta scalper then boom it just
takes off then you get the Delta scalper
gave a sell here this one didn't work
out but you know really tell me you know
which which chart looks much cleaner to
trade you know here you got this the
delta scalper Delta scalper Delta
scalper Delta scalper sell Buy sell buy
versus you know versus this chart you
know honestly that's why I prefer range
based charts because range based charts
move based on price activity not time it
doesn't just form a new bar because it's
9:15 I got to form a new bar no it move
forms a new bar when it breaks out of
its existing range that's why I trade
with range based charts so anyway I
wanted to keep this short you know I'll
throw bonds up you know just so I can
see you can see that really wasn't that
much in the bonds you know I don't say
oh Mike didn't show in the bonds because
the bonds you know had big losing day or
anything like that but um you know what
there really wasn't much to
trade in the bonds I mean you can make
the argument you know there's a couple
things in here that were interesting in
the bonds actually you had uh well the
slow is not that interesting you know
off the low you got Delta scalper giving
a buy okay but very tight range very
tight range then you start coming in
here you got 38 7 then you got 39 so you
got a lot less volume the second time
around you got the two divergences that
fail Divergence in a ratio started
selling off but then again you know this
is when the news hits you know you can't
anticipate that news is going to hit the
market like that that's going to affect
the market and then the market shot up
Delta scalper giving you a buy right
here so again you know you're coming
into the high you're going against two
failed divergences even though you had
this short here sort of countered with
this this is actually the Delta surge I
don't have the Delta surge on here but
this this would be it would be signaling
here as well Delta's really getting
aggressive here 144 985 1900 2400 again
all signals say to buy even if you're
getting late than buying at the high
it's it's a decent opportunity to be
buying at that high and you go up you
make new highs you come off make new
highs again so um you know there's a
couple things one I like second time you
hit the high you got less volume 39
versus 387 you do have a ratio and a
Divergence it didn't work out it started
to but obviously something else changed
um you got the the Delta scop are given
a buy then you start coming up into you
know area where you had some failed
divergences and you know if Market's
going to be trending you're going to end
up a day with a lot of failed
divergences so you know it's worth a
shot to take out that high that we could
go higher how high I don't know but um
you know once I'm looking for fail
divergences if I'm looking for a trend
day I want to see fail Divergence as we
take out this High it'll confirm the
fail
divergences Delta is really picking up
here it's getting getting very strong so
again you know all signs were there that
uh this Market can go higher which it
did okay so thanks for watching this
video um to learn more about orderflow
trading software using this presentation
visit my website orderflows decom and to
learn more about the delas scalper go to
deltas scaler.com and see um Fred I I
I'll check for your email again um I saw
your comments I'll I'll check I I'll
look again for email I thought I
responded but I'll double check maybe I
missed a different one in between but
anyway uh not to worry I I will reach
out to you again all right guys thanks
bye-bye